the uncovering of a painful past for
Generations a small Church Cemetery was
buried in the brush until parishioners
volunteers and descendants of those laid
to rest there began a massive cleanup
effort as cbs's Scott McFarland reports
they've brought new light on a dark part
of American history
behind the Sacred Heart Chapel in Bowie
Maryland a long forgotten Cemetery in
the 1700s the Jesuits founded a church
here and a plantation that kept people
enslaved including Kevin Porter's
ancestors this is where they live this
is where they
came to commune after
laboring all day as the Catholic church
acknowledges this horror of its past its
archdiocese in Washington recently
brought in an anthropologist to map and
document possible grave sites in an
overgrown area next to an existing
Cemetery so every stone
you know
firmly fixed in
you're going to Mark with a pink flag
as volunteers including church members
and some 7th and eighth generation
descendants swept raked and blew away
years of debris they saw centuries-old
Stones grave markers and indications of
burials oftentimes people you know
people who were enslaved people who are
people of color could not afford to buy
stones and so they marked grapes with
fieldstones is it possible dozens of
people were buried here it's likely that
hundreds of peoples are buried here with
this clearing process complete the
church will spend months now grappling
with how to properly Mark and preserve
what's really a tragic piece of the
church's history The Church says a
committee of descendants experts and
church leaders will eventually determine
how to Mark and honor the cemetery it's
part of the history
and it has been talked about
but needs to be talked about more other
organizations and governments are
seeking to do the same one of them the
state of Maryland has considered
legislation ordering a formal review of
burial places through the state to
determine where money is needed to find
and preserve burial grounds of historic
significance to the enslaved
African-American experience this is
where our ancestors
are buried or Kevin Porter hopes to see
a memorial on the site one day it's
important that we uncover them honor
them this site is important to our
family it's important to American
history I think we need Memorial is
telling those stories he hopes there is
learning and reflection in the future
from this piece of history for CBS
Saturday morning Scott McFarland Bowie
Maryland
the Committees is going to be their
lives mattered and they deserve being
remembered and so still do yeah so well
said there by Kevin have this moment to
learn from that and let's remember them
and honor them can't fully write these
wrongs but you can do something today
thank you